oh thank an exclusive yo saturnine 75
min bootleg keV live in studio the homie
and probably the hottest rapper on the
planet right now he goes by the name
city 2 Chainz with scuba true hey so uh
the first thing I gotta ask you about
bro is a kanye west just sent a tweet
and it says it you're officially
charging a hundred thousand dollars of
verse now because you're good G ood and
I'm like a double tonton will use for
the Thunder first of all it's been a lot
of rumors about you you officially
aligning yourself with good music so is
this is this the official announcement I
don't think it is not up like yo I don't
know he just said like I'm good like I'm
like I'm ill well we know that though
but you know we was talking to nerves
like I think I was jeopardizing my brand
sometimes but you know during the
homeboys special right so he you know
I'm think he just felt like we should
just put that out there that me doing no
more that so isn't there's gonna be a
decline in too good there's gonna be a
decline in um in in in two Chainz guest
appearances I say it's unless you know
you gotta do it if it's only if it makes
sense for yourself there you go that's
what it is right now you know me I would
have done almost anything a couple
months ago and it was all about really L
you know reaching out because you know I
still will I'm still grounded but it
just makes sense for me to slow down a
little bit being that I got an album
coming out August to 14th um I'm still
working on that based on a true story
coming august the 14th I got the single
out no lava drizzy drake so I'm just
trying to focus on two chains hanging um
so is there going to be a possible good
music def jam on the back of that album
when it drops but you remember I was
saying
hey can't kinky I mean is that our
jersey they're always good for real I
know I know that I'm saying that's some
hot joining some great features you know
me if you don't know anything about my
campaign I love the element of surprise
that's one thing they kind of Drew me to
hip hop you know I mean that's why the
no live record came out of nowhere with
Drake you know Drake has been a friend
of mine for years you know i mean if
people didn't even understand the
relationship much this no we had a song
coming so that being said I'm still into
the element of surprise you just got it
comin it's kind of state so your visual
statement or in steady state to me yeah
official statement is I have a album
coming out August affecting to Chinese
based on a true story that's my official
statement yo so I was talking to my man
Mike Posner who you got to be at home
you know you guys my dress my dog as
well hey he was telling me the way you
record is crazy he's like this doing
he'll chill with his cup his drink and
smoke listen to it you know the beat and
go in and at the most to taste to get
his verse down is he's like it's crazy
like to watch this guy work well well
did he tell you how he records I've seen
him record ever hear the chords adult
way too because he told he recall he
uses his mic Yeah Yeah right next to
them right right beside him on why he
sits down in a room full of people
that's talking you just have to oh damn
he's recorded nowhere yeah and and and
and he's like you know he felt
comfortable doing that because he used
to record a dorm room so I thought that
was dope right no sense so we both you
know we're intrigued by each other's
recording style so you know that being
said you know I mean um I do have a
jamming ass record with my posts gonna
be on the album I definitely love this
dude I don't know if I want to give that
much away we've done so many songs right
we're done over um we've done about five
or six songs together okay you know Oh
for him for just just working you know I
mean we sat down at a session to go I
don't want to get out of way cuz some
artists don't think not even out the box
like that but anyway it was some good
things they came out
so you know double salute the mic that's
my home how long um you know cuz the
whole the whole just not writing
anything down just kind of chilling
listening to the beat and then just
going in and record your verse have you
been doing that um the majority of your
time as an artist or is that something
that you recently started to do where no
I never wrote a verse down another Road
another right versus down another right
close friends and family members phone
numbers down any devices I i am a firm
believer of exercising your mind you
know not just your body and being that i
do things like smoke they made to tell
you what deteriorates your brain brain
cells and things like that i always
thought that if I could just remember or
think of it first in my head that could
be like and something stimulating my
brain my mind you know I mean not just
making that trade off a door yeah uh
kind of do so you know my road manager
my cousin all my home is at home like my
clothes people I just have that number
stored in my head you know I mean I'm
back when I was doing my hustling
thinking we were all that tool that was
one of the things that I did to where I
always felt like you know if I ever got
caught up or you know got any trouble
and they went through my phone it
wouldn't be anything jeopardizing you
know my mans and them and all that so
it's been some up in praising man since
since before I even got to this point I
was like this in school with retaining
information I mean I know back in high
school I never got to see at school and
people used to like spaz out like like
you know me I just remember certain
things and keywords out of certain
phrases of some you know me and it just
I just care it just carried along with
me indeed man I'm song I wanted to talk
to you about that is my favorite verse
of the year and I think it's a song that
not a lot of people of really um I don't
know I always be putting people onto
this joint the one with the weekend
sample I love that yo like me that verse
is insane bro he said and a [__] so
clean I go to church in it
um when you'd like decided to drop
because you're not uh you know since
since true religion you of course you've
been heavy on the features everything
but as far as like 2 Chainz records
there has been a lot of you know songs
that you just drop you and I mean online
or whatever that was one of them um has
there been a reason or you just just
kind of just saving all your all of your
stuff for the album yeah I'm definitely
getting ready for album oh um you know a
few songs are actually getting you know
hacked you know honestly you know I
never thought I could say they even be
that interesting but I really see stone
emailing period and then the songs that
are out that I put out purposely were
they had some kind of meaning behind it
right with with that particular joint it
was produced by DJ may know who's
Kanye's DJ and it was the same day i was
doing South by Southwest when I brought
out Kanye and so it was all like some
premeditated things that I was doing
calculated steps and sometimes I even
try to you know sometimes I overthink
things you know the name because I
actually love that song enough to
actually put it on my album to me and we
can't have a cool relationship I met him
on the Drake tour he's a cool-ass do you
know me rocks with the song and so uh I
don't know we just figured out you know
I mean before the most part being that I
put out an album I felt like I put out
an album with true religious people
indeed you know people enjoyed every day
you know I mean it's that camera is that
kind of music and being that I do so
many features constantly every week new
features pop up the kid continue keeping
me relevant and Marcus I don't you know
even consider putting out a mixtape the
next thing I put out I would like people
to really show me how much they support
my campaign without a free music I gave
out and went out you know it supported
my by spending a couple of dollars to
buy my project you feeling um the last
time I interviewed you you said that you
approach the mixtapes you make your mix
tapes when you make a true religion you
approach them as albums when you're
making your album you approach the
mixtapes his albums what is the real
approach man to the album because this
is your baby you know look right now
everyone's looking at you when I when I
work on albums are approaching like a
mixtape so
it's like no says it's just when it one
of the same it because I'm like you know
when I was working on mixtape sounds
like a lot of people can hear this where
albums people don't want to you know
really Bob spend their money to buy to
listen to the whole thing mixtapes they
give you a chance they could go to mix
tapes of that piff and listen to it yeah
yes so I would be like conscious about
what I will put on an hour really like
certain songs I do for people I my
example I do songs for people i took a
lot of my folk i said this we need to
make my mixtape you know about it just
be me talking you don't mean but i'll
still do it so when i'm working on this
album it's almost like i'm still getting
ready to put out a mixtape I just you
know I thought I'm gaining fans every
day so I feel like it's a lot of ears
gonna actually be on this project so I'm
just as geeky as I was when I was drop a
true and lives in coding in California
tribal belly not at all you know my
latest joints that really put me right
here your relationship with Kanye man
the mercy joint how important has that
song been to you so far man that that
song is like I feel like a lot of people
who might not have given you a shot as
far as like lyricism is concerned or or
maybe not giving you your Justin's MC
when that song came out I feel like a
lot of people like really were like okay
yeah now I know way so high well mine it
just shows you what a cosigner do it
with someone that doesn't really have
their own mind or go for because in my
opinion I really could have went hard on
the verse that's just me I thought you
went hard yeah I mean I did but I could
have went hard like you know are you
working on songs I remember that day I
done I probably did about four records
and I remember just trying to knock them
out and you know like never knowing
where ya be on you know me I'm not
knowing that he wanna make it a single
and put all this attention to it and
maybe that's good for me my boy from
Phoenix produced it yeah yeah I'm lifted
cool do and so uh you know you just you
just you just you know never know what
it is but with me every verse i do i put
my all into it so i'm happy with the
feedback over and all you know I me and
it got a lot of respect from from people
that otherwise weren't even paid and
attention to my campaign so that was
cool too and that's just you know why I
appreciate some other like Kanye cause
he's like influence you kind of guy and
when he rocking with some people kind of
paid today pay attention on me and
that's a blessing in the stuff and no
you had the input on it on the artwork
for the no life single yeah as far as
the album are you kind of i mean i'm
always a fan of still going out buying
seen using the story and having
something dope yeah i mean he's got a
special yes is dope is dope as hell man
i can't even lie man like I've been
having like I've been sitting down with
like some I've been sitting there like
some ill Cass and we've been throwing a
lot of ideas around and I do I already
kind of have to UM idea for how my own
album is gonna be packaged and
everything so I'm excited about that and
then um you know some a few other loan
you know marketing techniques I got
right I must leave that should be cool
as hell too but yeah right man yeah me
neither man that's the fun part you feel
I remember you know getting snoop and
yeah every Tuesday going step I did yeah
yeah people don't do met any nice to be
and now it's is the internet sport on
that for us man what am I gonna beat you
know that yeah you got it you gotta go
to the watch the throne route make sure
it doesn't leak you know yeah definitely
maybe that's why I'm that's maybe one
right there were home you know the last
thing I wanted to ask you about um was a
you could trending on Twitter for a
minute man every year the night you had
the like like things to change would say
that was reading did you look at it
because I was looking at some of the
lines people were like spit like you
know the right lines like it was coming
out of your mouth and that was like this
so brutal come with some pretty clever
line well with me um first of all that
day where there was a travel day for me
I was actually traveling to the chief of
San Francisco so I was on a plane from
Atlanta to the west coast for like four
or five hours so I missed the book of it
the other thing was that I didn't want
to read it and unconsciously thing some
I didn't I didn't even read it at all
but I just know it was funny people were
like we're having a good time out here
and I'm so into being an end
good you're not buying and doing my own
thing and just swing that you don't have
any of my thought powders is that I
didn't even want to look at it gotta
give you a big shout out for you know
let me uh rock with you on mtv2 for
spring break yeah that was a good look
for me who cares that kind of change a
lot you know and I was accidental for
both of us you know yeah shut up dje sir
that's my personal DJ he didn't even
flap MTV just told me they wanted me to
come up for um just to do my part of
super for equal Jeezy that I'm like I
can't do spend it no I can't do riot no
so like if you want to fly me in town
for one song but it like it's gonna be a
look you know how MTV oh Jesus can't
make it can you do 15 minutes oh oh oh
yeah yeah yeah so I can do riot yeah so
I need this minute yes what else do you
have for whatever else you got yeah so
that was cool great experience great
look um double salute to MTV is wood and
showed up yeah yeah that's been getting
a lot of burning yeah it should be it's
definitely gonna much love eight did you
hear the 50 riot remix yeah yeah i think
is dope yeah me too man cos dope he
definitely did it on his own but he put
my name into which a lot of people don't
doing there jack records yeah he's like
50 cent & 2 chainz I'm i like doing
that's dope he killed it he did it I
actually no food that we just not in
contact so I didn't feel any type of way
and then my hand fakers I'm trying to
unlink Oh link up with the champ you
know I mean I came out to write it so a
few people you know I me trying to make
both for our flamboyant styles collide
later on tonight somewhere you know a
fight you got it you got to be walking
out with George Bieber comes out with
full you guy gotta bring you in right of
little swag he came I got swag you gotta
come out so I dude
at man i'm in it I mean